salut dans cette 16e vidéo des énigmes
de l'été puisqu'on en a fait 32 donc on
est en plein milieu je vous donne une
nouvelle énigme bien sûr c'est le
concept de cette série mais surtout la
réponse à l'énigme d'hier s'était pas
vraiment une énigme à il ya un an
d'alice est un peu de la survie
comment faire pour trouver à coup sûr la
sortie d'un labyrinthe il suffit de
plaquer sa main sur le mur de gauche ou
sur le mur de droite et de le suivre
sans jamais lâcher la main du mur
nécessairement même s'il ya un cul de
sac ça va vous faire long j'ai toujours
le même mur et vous allez forcément que
ce soit celui de gauche ou de droite
trouver la sortie grâce à ça et si un
jour vous êtes enfermé dans un
labyrinthe vous penserez un mois alors
que la situation de l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui ça je pense pas non plus
que vous alliez les vivres alors c'est
vrai l'énigme d'aujourd'hui aussi aller
connu d'ailleurs on en a déjà parlé dans
des commentaires d'autres vidéos et
c'est justement comme ça que je me suis
rendu compte qu'il ya plein de personnes
qui la connaissait pas donc c'est pas
moi qui les cris d'un c'est une énigme
populaire qu'est vraiment connu imaginez
sur le bord d'une rivière il ya un homme
qui est sur la rive isla sa barque qui
flotte
il a avec lui un chou à lapin et un look
pourquoi ce mec-là 1 joue un lapin et un
loup j'en sais rien en tout cas il doit
leur faire traverser la rivière mais il
ne peut prendre qu'un des trois à la
fois c'est à dire que s'il prend le chou
il laisse les deux autres sur la rive
il ne peut pas mettre plus d'un élément
dans sa barque sur le principe je me dis
qu'il doit être quand même assez mal
foutu sa barque parce que bon si tu
prends le lapin là le chou lab ont les
moyens de se débrouiller lui il peut pas
meilleur sinon il y aurait pas d'énigme
faut savoir par contre qu'il peut pas
laisser le lapin et le chou tout seul
sinon le lapin mange le chou il peut pas
laisser non plus le renard et le lapin
tout seul sinon le renard bouffe le
lapin mais heureusement pour nous le
chou ne mange pas le renard ma question
est quand on prend en compte tous ces
éléments comment on va faire l'homme et
sa barque pour faire traverser les trois
sur l'autre rive comment il va se
débrouiller pour qu'à la fin les trois
est lui-même soit sur l'autre rive et
non il n'a pas le droit de jeter le
lapin comme un ballon en utilisant la
barque à chaque fois cherchez bien ne
donnait pas la réponse dans les
commentaires je suis sûr qu'il a plein
qui la connaissent ils vous la
connaissez m'étais juste je connaissais
mettait un pouce en l'air pour qu'on
sache le nombre de personnes qui
connaissent la réponse ou qui ont trouvé
la réponse
et moi je la donnerai demain matin à 11
heures profitez bien de votre samedi du
soleil de la plage sortait fait la fête
amusez vous pensé quand même à vous
abonner avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 11h ciao